chérie je vais vous dire jusqu'au 10
questions vous aviez été payés quand
vous étiez chroniqueurs oui c'est vrai
ça changeait pour sa chronique à vous à
nous dire
le premier mot qui me vient à l'esprit
benjamin castaldi jeu fermé pour moi
pour moi légende les gens je vous dis
les gens des gens vont beinheim moi j'ai
élégance et des gants jean michel et son
qui souffre dit élégant soit ils sont
toujours beau et c'est pas sympa moi
jean michel jarre il dit à un plan
expliqué que je le vois on parle d'un
plan parce que moi j'ai une calvitie
glissante décembre elle prend de plus en
plus confiance en elle mais qu'elle
visitera monde a peur ça fait peur et ça
me fait pas du court je parle avec
formation leur calvitie à l'histoire car
kim dong d'evry conseil non ça rigolait
bas les mêmes cliniques ans au plus il
avait deux solutions ouest et une maison
ont été léchées par soudaine à ims et
d'élégance ça c'est vrai qu'avec des
femmes élégantes ici moi moi j'avais dit
à ma grande soeur savannah de s'auto
franzen c'est bien ça lui a mis un coup
un gros dealer faut vous dire ah non moi
j'adore ça je recherche
oui éléphants d'efforts il est pour lui
plus inquiète pas coutume comme la gale
attaqué comme çà
[Applaudissements]
una vez moi je dirais essentiel même si
il est toujours piqué keita mais il est
essentiel pour moi il est égal à zéro en
fin de l'émission après ces matches
auxerre icônes et où isabelle morini
bosc a relaté isabelle le coeur non
c'est beaucoup et là mais mon bon oui le
coeur ça veut dire que le coeur marche
encore sacha elbaz
[Applaudissements]
mr choi m'a dit qu'on n'est pas cadré sa
troisième émission bas alors sur sa
fraîcheur sa famille après chercheurs
c'est bien pourquoi c'est quoi ton sur
ton prénom l'appel petits cochons
il est même pas au courant lui c'est
vrai qu'on le verra demain vous verrez
dans la digue puisqu'il on l'appelle le
petit khallouf un petit biscuit et nous
ces petits biscuits que jeu qui m'a on
embrasse franchement lutins depuis quand
tu cites un truc et sa part qu'on a fait
ça a changé la donne et combien la régie
la nouvelle alors je vais ça n'a pas
coûté d'argent
celui ci jointe est le sens avec bon
entendeur pour la sortie le soir il part
mais non la vraie relation car c'est
demain faudrait que j'arrête
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi pour vous elle adore ses
interventions donc c'est propre à moi
j'ai juste s
c'est vrai en italie c'est gentil moi
j'irais même de justesse que chaque soir
[Applaudissements]
et on va perdre a dit jeudi que vous
voulez c'est le dark side de me
critiquer ce qu'il a dit c'est gentil
d'abord ouais mais j'aurais pu dire
légende aussi mais j'aime me dire le
papa pour moi c'est papa tout maintenant
c'est un bon savon conseil mais classe
qui connaît tout le monde tienne
l'expérience allez allez on parle
vraiment d'un arbre s'est nouée big foot
avait dit quoi non moi j'avais 10 ans de
l'être humain mais sa voix aussi bah oui
non mais il arrêtait vous avez arrêté un
méchant je vous dis celui ci avait donné
un conseil à l'époque il était un peu
timide et red moi j'ai toujours cru en
eux j'ai dit vous allez faire bercy vous
allez bien sur une plage omaha agadir
voilà c'est vrai alors que nous en fait
bercy un carton ah ouais on avait peur
bien sûr l'époque ya edith piaf à lui a
dit tu as par vidéo gag
[Applaudissements]